deux secondes et la porte s'ouvre en
voici le morpho portier où les débuts de
la reconnaissance faciale en france la
machine est le programme tient compte du
vieillissement de votre visage de votre
morphologie et c'est donc une adaptation
rafraîchissement de la mémoire du
système
les concepteurs l'ont imaginé pour des
entreprises sensibles à haute sécurité
mais d'imaginer à terme un usage
généralisé au quotidien se produit ce
qui est passée ce qui va se substituer à
la clé à la clé au code pin ce que vous
voulez aucune contrainte mode créé ou la
peur des portes sur visage votre code
pin vous l'oubliez pas sur votre visage
ainsi de suite cette technologie
s'appuie sur un stockage de données
personnelles et de caractéristiques
physiques et si elles étaient
généralisées
faudrait-il imaginer une société où tout
le monde pourrait être identifié
surveillez scrutés au nom de la sécurité
la reconnaissance faciale fait craindre
une atteinte aux libertés individuelles
déjà en 2000 la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est que ce passe-t-il lorsque
une puissance mal intentionnés manipule
cette molécule
la france n'en est pas là elle a surtout
recours aux empreintes digitales et à la
reconnaissance de l'iris dans certains
cadres très contrôlé mais déjà en 2007
le comité national d'éthique alerte sur
une banalisation des technologies
biométriques
si de l'identité du contrôle de
l'identité on passe au contrôle des
comportements on peut aller à toutes les
dérives libertés individuelles contre
sécurité à tout prix à la suite des
attentats de 2015
la recherche s'est accélérée des
spécialistes de la biométrie annonce des
systèmes de caméra pouvant identifier
des personnes recherchées capables de
suivre des personnes suspectes de
déceler des comportements violents
même au milieu d'une foule dans le métro
dans la rue n'importe où tout à fait
c'est un logiciel qui permet de capter
l'ensemble des visages l'ensemble dans
flux passagers et qui va identifier les
personnes recherchées qui sont déjà
contenue dans une base individu
dangereux de terroristes plus que jamais
le ministère de l'intérieur se montre
favorable à un recours à la
reconnaissance faciale
que ce soit pour l'accès à des services
en ligne où pour la sécurité dans les
rues le dispositif des polémiques un
monde du tout scruté comme en chine
devenue société de l'ultra surveillance
[Musique]